Sports Complex what are we seven
thousand square feet something like that
yes so we I did the largest BMX mountain
bike skate family-oriented facility in
the world so action sports is the
fastest-growing sport in this last ten
years kids from eight years old to 21
years old they all want to do something
different you know they've been writing
they've been doing baseball football
basketball and you know action sports
seems like it's something new and
exciting so I had to do something for
everyone
why did you pick North Carolina North
Carolina I lived in Greenville because
one of the best BMX riders his name is
Dave me or live there so I trained there
I did most of my competing years there
and then what was looking into moving
and starting a new complex I was like
where should I go and I looked into
Raleigh and Raleigh seemed like one of
the fastest growing economy in America
and when I looked in closer I looked at
Holly Springs which is where the complex
is and that's number one place in
America for families so it just made
sense you know that when I moved in
December i-i've around my street and I
all I see is kids you know so this is a
sport that uh yes it might be a little
intimidating for some just because I
think it's just not well-known like
maybe football or basketball but you
know I made sure that when I built the
complex it was something that I can
build trust with parents I have medical
staff on-site at all times so they know
if something happens we have problems
first response responders a bill rants
from for someone that's never touched a
buyer or skater before - all the way to
someone that can compete professionally
so you know I put a lot of thought into
this thing I'm just happy it's finally
finally open all right now you didn't do
this necessarily alone because you've
got sponsors and other organizations
that are helping you tell us about that
well so for when I started the complex I
joined with two other business partners
Abel sorcerer and Chilton Olander and
they've been great help Abel Salisbury's
been in in North Carolina and the
Raleigh area for over ten fifty years
Chelsea has lived there for a long time
so they helped me a lot to understand
the area and what I needed to do in the
area so you know when we were talking
about what I wanted to do us like well
I want to do a family-oriented facility
but I don't want this to be like any
other parking around the country or
around the world I want this to be
top-notch I want this to be clean I want
this to be neat I want when people walk
in to be like whoa they took their time
and thought this this whole thing
through so you know just being with them
it's been great just because we've been
able to to make that Daniel what is the
the most amazing
I don't know trick or move that you've
done with BMX bicycles in maybe three
four years ago I invented this trick
called the cash roll so it's kind of
hard to explain you probably need to see
a video but it's a I'll do a 180 I do a
back flip and then another 180 an eight
a 180 a back flip and then another 180
yes it's a little intricate move I don't
really bring it out often it's it's hard
and confusing once you're in the air but
it's a great trick